my name is Anders Nordquist and I'm CEO
of Asteria so the business model is we
sell smart cash flow to financial
institutions and they in return they
integrate this into their online bank
and then they offer it to their existing
small medium-sized
local entrepreneurs everything we do we
connect to a visual because that's what
we believe strongly and that's what
people want that's what people can
connect and relate to we can go into a
forest and we can see we can smell we
can touch we can feel what is edible but
when you work in IT you don't get the
touch you don't get the smell you get
the visual using visuals to enable AI or
to enable people to access it that's key
to what we do that means you get a
visual of what banking products do for
you and your business and that's
absolutely unique today on the market
we're a cloud native company we never
had any other option or a will for that
matter to put our data and hosting
anywhere else than in the cloud no one
can question the integrity of IBM as a
cloud provider
I think AI will revolutionize the world
that's genuinely what I think it's not
gonna happen over a day but in the next
five to ten years we will see changes in
anything from the public sector to small
business owners to governments and large
enterprises to save more time and to
make people's lives easier
[Music]